[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about
whatever we want i'm done
hello hello hey hello what's up
um oh you got a fresh fade where'd you
go you got a vince i cut my own hair
actually oh
you cut it down here you start doing
your own now he has a barber shop you
cut it here
yeah i got it here that looks good i
knew i was gonna be on camera as well
you said you did everyone else's but
your own
so today you were like i'm gonna fade my
own i had time
yeah yeah cause i didn't know you cut
your own hair yeah that's a whole nother
i don't like to because it takes like
two to three hours
what why you put on two movies just
because you can't see yeah you can't see
the back of your head as much
you don't have a mirror do you switch
the clippers to the other hand or use
one hand for all that i try to use one
hand because my left hand just sucks
because i can't bend my left thumb
if you practice oh never mind cause you
can't bring yourself i cut my
you remember when i cut my thumb really
bad oh yeah i remember that yeah i cut
some nerves
and it's going to take years of rehab
weren't you doing dishes and like it
broke or something like
this is a glass cup i just rinsed it i
was gonna put it in the
drying rack it slipped out of my hand my
dumb ass my natural
interesting was like i gotta save this
glass cup that's about to shatter so i
go boom i push it against the table
squirt's like two feet of blood oh we
always your rehab you just play thumb
wars with people
yeah yeah i mean he just said you just
bend it every day you just try to bend
it oh like
can you this is the most i could go like
this let me honestly see what the
difference is
oh [ __ ] what that's the most i could
mention i've been there dude nerve
damage is a trip
it's a joke it's no joke he said it
might take years just remember how to
bend your thumb again oh no
that's what happened to me but you
become a baby i've talked about this
before but i fell asleep on my hand
and it was like this that's the funniest
thing ever yeah it's real too it's
[ __ ] crazy steve walking around with
this yeah dude it was like this
it was my right hand i'm right-handed so
i was just like [ __ ] and so
it helped because i put it in like a
little brace or whatever you could have
made up so many cool stories because no
one knows
right no one knows around here i know
you could have said so many
you could have said you were like a
secret agent i should have i know
it's all funny but no it's a trip
because the doctor's like you might not
be able to move it for years
if it even comes back at all because
nerves are you know what people just
think now people just think that you sat
on your hand on purpose you try to jack
off with it so it feels like a different
person
and then you sat on it for too long i
don't even think of that that doesn't
even feel that good
no oh i did it didn't do anything you
can't jerk off with it like
like you can't even close your trying
hard enough no there's nothing to
there's nothing to put your dick in dude
if if joe had that he would figure it
out that's true
oh yeah i had to go to rehab like an
actual rehab facility with
with experts and they were helping me
and it was like so [ __ ] up because i
was there with like
iraq war veterans and afghanistan
veterans and [ __ ] and i'm just like
fellas in my hand i'm sorry i [ __ ]
shouldn't even be here i'm a piece of
[ __ ]
damn geez i had to do physical therapy
for this
this uh this tendon here after giving
birth to isaac
and like nursing and stuff they said
like i
i exhausted my tendon and apparently
it's really common for
postpartum women to have this particular
tendon wait [ __ ] was it this one
[ __ ] and i forgot jill had something
like that too something to do with the
pregnancy like i think there's like
bloating
that happens in here so like it pushes
all the the bones or the tendons like
weird
is this one geo's wrists are bloated
they are huh
that's why i keep telling her yeah it's
crazy but yeah like they've had me do
like
loaded wrists exercises like this and
like i had to like
massage it and it would like pop it was
so
painful is it better now oh yeah it's
been it's been like baby arms because
they look like balloons
you know they look like a balloon animal
like you see the wrist it goes into the
wrist and goes boom
they're really chunky that was taika
taco is pretty chumpy you see this
he still has it he still has it's like
it's like puffy goes around
isaac was never a chunky baby so he
didn't have those babies
those rolls oh my baby's chunky yeah
they're so much cuter when they're
chunky i've been to
physical therapy before after i got into
my motorcycle accident but i felt like i
i treated it like all the other things
doctors recommend me for me to do like
if they give you medicine you know then
i finish the whole bottle and i finish
like half and i'm like i'm good that's
like me with my retainer
i didn't even wear it yeah look they're
all [ __ ] up now
yeah that's just it man it's so it's
annoying what was your physical therapy
thing what did you have to
specifically do it was like because i
felt like when i was there it was like
[ __ ] that like i was like oh it's kind
of like working out
but like on a smaller scale so i was
like oh just i'll just do it on my own
you know like [ __ ]
you know shoulder raises and rotations
and stuff so what was messed up from the
accident
it was a i broke uh my wrist like the
bone here
oh so then it it kind of like goes up
all the way to the arm and i had the
cast all the way to my armpit um so then
i had to like
you one you have to learn how to use
your hand correctly anymore and also
your entire shoulder
like it was just stiff from that like or
this and also all the way
i think off my other arm because this
one didn't break but it got [ __ ] up so
this one i had to
wow get it damn i was there
you were there what do you mean you were
there like a motorcycle accident no
i just i just told him because he you
know lived nearby and i was like hey i
got
i got into the accident like or i was
just like hey what are you doing and
then he was like
i'm in the area you said i was eating oh
yeah
i mean i'm not never mind i'm cool that
i'm an urgent care i'm like what why are
you urging her he's like oh it's just
constant motorcycle accident
yeah and i was like oh don't worry about
it then it's cool i drove there at me
and this guy's just like oh i'm fine
his legs all like [ __ ] up his arms his
arms like [ __ ] up were you bleeding
and [ __ ] all right
uh on my like leg i was bleeding yeah i
was like a bit
i will get on my motorcycle again he did
oh that's just like that guy he's
working my bike last night spent the
entire day working i can't wait to go
riding with you dude
yeah i mean i thought because i i had a
neighbor that lived in my um
it was like a duplex right and he
actually lost his finger
when he was working on his bike like it
popped off when he was working on it
yeah so
when you're cleaning your chain you're
supposed to like have it on the ground
roll it forward clean the chain a little
bit
but he was doing the thing that they
tell you not to do which is he had the
engine on
going and he wanted to just oil the
chain and clean it with a rag and his
finger got caught and it pulled in
so it was like a clean pop-off right and
then he was just like oh [ __ ]
so he went to the hospital hey you're
pretty good at detailing bikes yeah
i gotta bring my bike over okay you have
a bike
oh yeah he just got one i just got one
oh [ __ ] congrats
thank you that's tight yeah but then he
used it i asked him about it he was like
yeah he wrote again within two weeks of
popping off his finger
because he he told himself i guess he
was like if i don't ride now then i'm
never going to do it
so then so inspirational that's crazy i
mean he was a professional like
writer oh yeah like on the track for you
what prevents you from not wanting it i
mean like yeah what prevents you
most people like they eat it or
something like i don't
i don't want to do this anymore but i
think because i knew it was my fault
so i'm like i i just need to be better
like i need to improve my skills i need
to practice
i need to be more aware so like it feels
[ __ ] like that just happened to me i
guess i would be a lot more scared but
all the accents i've been to been into
like if i was a better rider i think i
could have afforded how many axes have
you been on a motorcycle
dude motorcyclists this is the common
refrain yeah they tell you like
it's not if you get into that it's when
yeah and 95 percent
it's because people run into you not
because of the writer yeah it's because
you guys are elusive [ __ ] you just
somehow managed to fit in the five
percent they say that but at the same
time like if you talk to people who like
like i don't know teach and stuff they
they teach you a lot of different
maneuvering methods to really try to
avoid these situations
you know like like of course if someone
turns out in front of you it's like oh
how could you know right
but if you're a writer who thinks that a
car is always gonna turn out in front of
you
you avoid try to you could try to
maneuver a little bit better like it's
not always the case of course
but like you you could definitely try
harder i drive
like i am always in a 99 ranch parking
lot
that's smart that is that is like the
wild west out there
right it's like you're just driving
through and you don't know which car is
going to come [ __ ] back in a shopping
cart you don't know who's backing up
because they don't look back
that's like a costco shopping uh i'll
have a costco
any costco it's the same [ __ ] it's a
nightmare
wait how did you pick out your bike um
i've been looking for it for like ages
and then um i kind of just forgot about
it until i was in
jersey and then um i rode my buddy's
bike
because it was there and he left it
outside and had frost and [ __ ] so i was
like
yo we gotta thaw this out so we thawed
out the bike and then
i was riding it and i was like oh yeah
this is pretty fun is there any reason
why you wanted a cruiser
i always like cruisers but um what does
that mean
like the position you're kind of like
your feet in front of you but wait is it
like this
no not necessarily it looks like a
chocolate that's the [ __ ] mess
you know yeah
because i don't really care about going
extremely fast and i don't care about
like i don't know i just want to be
comfortable i want a comfortable ride i
have a picture i want to see what it
looks like i love this yeah
i want to i want a comfortable ride it's
like they're almost like hanging on dude
yeah dude they're like you know why
because i got a huge [ __ ] that's why
the april how is that comfortable i i
like the way it looks it looks
hilarious it makes me feel like they're
uncomfortable
like they're like the blood is just like
they don't have any blood
yeah you don't see it much here but it's
i mean there's a lot of things that
don't make sense that people do like
hardtails i think hard times are cool
what's that one and hardtails like
there's no suspension like in the rear
it's just like the tire and then your
ass yeah so any crap
you feel any yeah any like speed bump
it's like strange
but it's for cosmetic like it's cool
it's like it's like the la thing or it's
like it's cool for that community
yeah like it's bad for handling it's bad
for your body like
like the the thing about suspension it's
not about really making you comfortable
it's like
keeping the tires always touching the
ground as much as possible yeah so if
you hit a bump
without a suspension yeah it's probably
gonna lift up in the air for a little
bit oh sure that's scary so that's bad
but they're not meant to haul ass in
anyway oh but people do they do yeah
because it's all about that out loud
life
yeah no i like i wanted just something
comfortable and like i can ride for long
distance because i want to go
like i don't really want to do much city
riding but i want to do more like
hit the pch or go like maybe to vegas or
like
go on like open land and then maybe go a
little
i was gonna get one of those like uh
what do you call it they're not quite
enduro but they're like mixed dual
sports or scramblers so like
i could i could ride it it's street
legal and then i could go out into the
mountains
if i wanted to imagine you would have
done that that would probably be more of
my style but then i think a cruiser was
more practical for my first bike
so i got that instead uh i'm against it
for
the rebel the both of you i don't ride
hard though and i don't write stupid
tell you when i get my bike then
i'm gonna start for you too i don't know
i've been riding if you work on bikes
and you get stains you know what helps
you get stains out
oxi clean max force the new oxiclean max
force because today's video is sponsored
by oxiclean max force
shocker so if you're working on
motorcycles and you get stains on your
stuff like i'm sure
you probably do right tile stains or
whatever you can use oxy
clean max force to help get the stains
out because today's video is sponsored
by oxiclean max force and they get
rid of all kinds of stains from blood
from oil from like cooking stains and
it's really helpful
especially if you like having your
whites look white
and you don't want to have like little
yellow spots it's really helpful because
it has a gel built into the thing and
you could just scrub it
or if you have if you use the spray you
can just spray and let it sit overnight
and then tomorrow
you throw it into the washing machine
and it comes right out and it's super
convenient and it tackles the toughest
dried in stains with five types of stain
fighters
to remove grease oil grass blood soil
clay
food and drinks the first time which is
really important
yup you can spray now wash up to a week
this is a good especially when you are
pre-treating
a dried on stain okay so you gotta try
oxiclean max force
for yourself to work your magic with
oxiclean go to oxiclean.com
maxforce1 to get a coupon for one
dollar off baby i do get a lot of stains
you do right when you ride no we're
working my bike
oh do you get like do you wear apron
then you know some of those i do have
i do have i always just forget i have it
that's the problem but i do have one
like joe has a picture of me in it
yeah it's a pretty sick apron his
workers uh it's nice because like a lot
of times when you're um
cutting metal it's like the sparks are
flying into your body yeah
that's so cool what's the material made
out of like rubber like canvas
and normally you want cotton because it
will just
like it won't melt onto your body oh you
know like something like a
like synthetic like that's why you can't
have motorcycle clothes that's like
synthetic a lot of times unless it's
bike specific because then like fake
leather could melt onto your body from
in like a slide and then it'll stay on
there now yeah now it's
attached to your skin oh my god now
become real leather oh [ __ ]
as a biker if you ever saw a guy so a
couple years ago i remember seeing
something went viral on reddit where a
guy had a
dark knight like christopher nolan dark
knight motorcycle
outfit with the helmet that's pretty
sick and the costume
as a biker how would you guys feel about
sick that's sick
yeah my friend has a boba fett helmet
really yeah they make
all the star wars stuff but you're
talking about the whole outfit with the
cape and everything that's
extra no cape just everything it's
really dangerous the arm [ __ ] and
everything no games
no capes made me laugh because i'm like
this
this guy's just asking to get his ass
or can he might be [ __ ] sturdy
no you'd be surprised by how open the
biker community is like you could
show up at any meet and you're any kind
of person everyone from every
background's there it's pretty
surprising yeah okay
they're like super welcoming i mean of
course there's some like
people who aren't as nice yeah angels
angels meet but they accept me like oh
they look probably not
there's a gang they might have to like
jump you first
i don't know i don't know how that works
i get a sick jacket after
oh that's true i feel like i forgot
everything i learned at that
course that cause like i i mean so do
you have your license i do have my
license
and if i would get i had a dream
recently
again because i've been having these
dreams on and off here but
it's a dream of me approaching a
motorcycle and me
being like okay what did i learn again
how do i do this
and then somehow i get it to go but then
it leaves me
oh and then like you fall off the
motorcycle goes and you're just like
what the [ __ ]
no like i ride for a little bit and then
something happens where like i'm just
standing there
and then the bike just left by itself
you don't know my bike damn what do you
think that's about
i think it means that all the the
knowledge i learned
it's leaving me that's pretty direct you
know what i um
the first time i wrote it in jersey i
almost forgot
everything but it's just without when i
stopped thinking about it everything
came back
when i thought too much i was like wait
where's all the things
but then when i was just sitting there
talking to my friend i was like
yeah oh cool it was weird yeah muscle
memory yeah your body right and when i
test drove it too i was like
kind of nervous because i was like wait
no i got this
and then i got on and i just wrote it
are you trying to go in like twisties
and stuff in the mountains
not now eventually yeah eventually yeah
yeah but i'm
you know i'm on a cruiser i'm not like
trying to do liens and [ __ ] like
hardcore
leans look at this these [ __ ]
talking i'm not trying to do leans and
shreds and all that [ __ ] i'm trying not
to do spikes and all that
actually really oh you
steve thought it was a thing i'm cute
what no that's not an actual thing
leans is another thing i mean i guess
you kind of lean you technically are
[ __ ] hilarious you just made this
[ __ ] up [ __ ] big dick in it with this
[ __ ] motorcycle talk
i think he means like oh you know i'm
not trying to drag me or something cute
i like it
well because there's something called a
leaning class so they're not touching
the floor
that's why you have um the people who
are really into it like their pants have
the velcro
so you can stick on like the pucks onto
their knees and as you drag me over time
it like
grinds away you get a new one our
instructor
for the written part remember that chick
she says that that's what she
specializes oh yeah she does that stuff
that's crazy
yeah that's dangerous and she showed us
photos and she's like
she's like you dropped the ground yeah
that's nuts yeah i was in the
i was in malibu like a week ago and i
finally
like got to the point where i was like
um grinding down my foot pegs
as i go like you kind of hear it go and
i was like okay time to finally like
put my rear sets in the back of my bike
i have no i still haven't gone on the
actual road because i'm scared
so we got the heart we got you right
around your neighborhood yeah we got the
harleys
uh who were doing like that whole
sponsorship thing i would just ride
around the neighborhood
and once i get comfortable i'm i'm gonna
take it on the street and right when i
get to the intersection i'm like
and i see cars coming by my knob i go
back and forth i want to watch you
to make the youtube yeah just go right
back at you just make like a five-point
u-turn
i think riding the scooters in vietnam
was probably scarier than motorcycle
the scooter's against the different
world algorithmic and everything it's
because i don't understand it i've
always wanted to try it's fun though
but you'll get used to it like that
because there's some weird organized
chaos that's happening
and it's like everyone's going their own
direction but then there's a flow to it
and then you start to get it it's just
this
i don't know i just think it's just
different like we're used to our flow
with traffic right
like and and and we i don't know we have
every [ __ ] man for himself no i think
it's funny because when we look at their
traffic it's scary but when they come
over here they think ours is scary yeah
so like my cousins when they came here
they moved here they they had to get
learn how to drive a car and stuff and
they were so scared to go on the freeway
or whatever
even though it's like straight pads we
go faster we go faster
like they're going it's it's all over
the place but it's like what can you
make i think just the nature of driving
is different so when i ride scooters in
taiwan
i don't really feel scared at all
because like i think in america the way
you drive
you're always right everyone else is
[ __ ] up and because of that like
you're trying to prove that on the road
at least in taiwan it feels like oh let
me let me oh should you come here okay
go ahead go ahead
it has like it's a way different feeling
so it almost feels like as i'm going i'm
just
in a much friendlier environment so if i
[ __ ] up people aren't gonna flip me off
they don't like
it's not it's not like uh like you know
here if there's
one lane open two cars are trying to
[ __ ] squeeze into that like i gotta
hear your first [ __ ] so like
when i'm
pulling the motorcycle into the street
it almost already feels like everyone
wants to run me over if i don't get in
on time
versus in taiwan it's not aggressive out
there it's just
crazy oh [ __ ] we got a new guy we got a
new guy we got a new guy go ahead go
away you know so it just feels like wait
out here if somebody even stopped
because like if i pull up to the stop if
they put the stop sign first
i'm gonna wait for them but if they're
like oh go ahead i'm like what the [ __ ]
that's not the rules dude
you're supposed to go first actually
it's a dick move to be too polite
yeah it can be it can be because then
you'll be wrong
if he went exactly yeah for me i really
want to see what it's like to ride a
bike that
like is smaller because the one that we
learned on it was
bigger than what i feel like should be
for my size i'll let you know when i
finish my second bike
yeah small one yeah it's like 175 cc so
yeah what is it a cafe racer i'm gonna
turn it into like a scrambler but it's
like uh
it's a 74 like honda it's like
it's kind of like a dual sport but back
in the day it's like listening to pilots
so oh yeah we do we do a twenty one so
it's like it looks like a dirt bike
yeah but the old ones aren't plasticky
you know like the tank is metal
everything's metal still but
maybe i should look into this stuff
because i i never once
looked down people who ride bikes i feel
like most people who also drive cars
you know like they don't know anything
about their oil changes they don't know
anything about their tire pressures no
one knows anything
no yeah i mean my bike i rode for like
years i didn't know [ __ ] until i finally
got into my accident an older rebel
might be good for her the 250s
but i really want to know what that
feels like though because during the
class every time
like my favorite thing was when we were
we were going up to speed and i was able
to turn and like lean like that was my
favorite feeling ever but when you go
and then you look where you're at
you also look where you're going
but then everyone's like look more look
more
look more over the shoulders when i
started getting comfortable i didn't do
it as much yeah and then my instructor
is like going like this he's like
i'm [ __ ] watching it it is a big deal
though in the castle canyons and you're
going you have to like
look where you're going because most of
the actions that happen is because
you're kind of looking forward and your
bike goes where you're looking yeah yeah
that's literally they kept saying that
like a million times throughout the
whole course was
your bike will go where you live that's
not even joking that's what people do
for like real hard turns no but then
when we had at the like for the
test we had to do the zigzag part and
because the bike was so
[ __ ] huge and heavy i i [ __ ] up a
couple of times where i almost didn't
even pass my test
i don't know if you would even like a
cruiser because if you like the feeling
of turning
cruises don't lean us no it's hard to
turn it in like
yeah our bikes were pretty big though
you